[Musique]
grand-sault ou b guerre une nouvelle
épreuve de haute voltige
[Musique]
rotation dans tous les sens quelques
secondes pour en mettre plein
[Applaudissements]
comment maximiser le nom d'acrobaties
aériennes
démonstration avec un des maîtres de la
discipline sébastien toutant le premier
objectif
allonger le temps de vol perché à 50
mètres de haut
la quête s'élance
le tremplin à des fêtes une catapulte
et en y ajoutant sa propre impulsion il
peut gagner jusqu'à trois mètres de
hauteur
assez pour compléter sa routine
sa vitesse joie notre rôle clé celui de
faciliter la rotation
[Musique]
pendant la descente le planchiste de
passe de 70 kilomètres à l'heure
quand il aborde le tremplin il s'incline
vers l'arrière là ces jambes prendre les
devants et plus la position du compact
plus cette rotation accélère
[Musique]
il existe un deuxième type de rotation
qui suit lax du corps
l'aubergiste pivote sur lui-même et
cette fois l'énergie
les premières vagues de la descente car
la planche doit rester immobile
parallèle à la piste jusqu'au tout
dernier moment sur le tremplin
l'athlète projette ses bras pour créer
une torsion puis tout son corps se
déroule de haut en bas
la rotation atteint aux jambes au moment
exact où la planche quitte le tremplin
[Musique]
ce coup de fouet permet d'exécuter
quatre tours
et même d'attenté un cinquième
la plupart des sceaux combine des
rotations dans les deux axes d
enchaînement complexe qui ont un
avantage pour l'athlète celui de voir le
sol
[Musique]
lors de chaque passage la tête en bas
l'athlète évalue sa trajectoire
s'oriente dans l'espace
[Musique]
d'enjeux décider s'il a le temps de
compléter sa routine
aussi doit changer de place
[Musique]
pour freiner la rotation l'athlète dépit
son corps il doit absolument atterrir
avec la planche dans laxe de la pente
s'il veut conserver l'équilibré est
épaté à la fois les juges et punis
[Applaudissements]